comment if you are interested you can
find them on professor close personal
weblog which is going to inform comment
porn cool calm now we are going to open
the life and take your questions I would
appreciate that you if you would address
your questions to a specific number of
paths this
is there any theoretical Islamic Jeremy
legal dispute between a medida John & Co
stanky or is it just below or is it just
a political conflict of the physical I
guess which can be up the horses welfare
but would you like to
yep why you asking about whether
ok
I mean is are they he's a popular
president I do not feel that he has the
ideology or I do not understand most of
the audience the audience called him
selected president me that he was not
elected was selected by a leader and no
also the leader and the stupid he made a
mistake writing less than seven months
eight months
another age at the beginning at Medina
John said that I'm follower of fight
amongst what is it clear she instantly
hit hard by the education after
sometimes also love is for unity tonight
not my vision so because of you like
total I do not know any ideology for
different feminists were speaking of one
thing came across the deck seems to be
many parallels between the hierarchy of
the sheer clergy's and yahoo church so I
would like to hear the comments of each
of the speakers to see you know what
their take is on it because of a for
instance we say election of the phone
but it's covered in election Israeli
selection and 13 people and they get
together and you know one person is
event
keep your question your question you're
asking the analysts to arrest these
similarities and differences would be
shared clerical hierarchy and the
pontifical hierarchy of the Catholic
Church but let's begin with professional
um
right I understand that so let's let's
let's see if how specific the mms which
would like to get this so well you know
the shared with religious authorities
are not hierarchical form the way
catholic church is it's a much more
fluid kind of structure if it's a
structure at all so individuals choose
which of the clergyman they want to
choose i want to follow and and then the
clergy themselves will defer to someone
that they respect and so forth it's
really a little bit more like the system
among televangelists i mean who is the
most popular preacher on TV is the one
that has most followers and so forth
there is that aspect to it although you
couldn't get any place just by being a
popular preacher you'd also have to
write the kind of books that would
attract these team of one's peers but
there's no appointment you know seized
on you got to be where he is over time
I've had politics of reputation there
was never a moment of which there was an
election or arrays of selection either
in the Comenius system there is a more
formal selection process
though maybe that's a little bit more
like the Cahuenga system is a little bit
more like solecism in the sense that the
supreme there's a supreme leader and
he's his own mind at least often
considered unchallengeable and and so
forth but but even then i think the the
big difference between Islam and
religious ism is that the Roman
Catholicism it is institutionalized
hierarchical Church and just don't have
that church like structure in Islam is
much more personal mystic and fluid and
changing I think for the sake of Allah
you like to comment on that hope you
like the pattern evening there are
different approaches among shades one of
it is close to Roman Catholicism and
another is against the first approach is
a leader and working I want to
distinguish between choosing the leader
and selecting the she automatically I
think it's two different cases to choose
the leader according to Iranian
Constitution it should be selected or it
should be elected by the
a committee of the experts my physical
Ricardo Microsoft overall it's something
like the Cardinals among the countries
so it means and also is Cardinal for
field experts are selected by elected by
the people elected by the citizens it
should be in this way that's actually
really a leader and selected the members
of this Parliament the member of his
fourth member of Titusville Ferreira and
so another approach is the leader is not
their representative of the seminary's
not representative of his clergy is
immediately shoot the underhand of their
under power of the media we have these
two approaches in Iran for example even
daily is the representative of hard
liners it means that the leader should
be above the Serena Serena we should
follow them like the other fundamental
is in Iran the same at all traditional
is
the dealer so that is nice
representative they believe that the
leader is the representative of Serena
so it's completely two different
approaches and the third approach is
what I pulled off one has any loss I to
da moon has risen and I converse history
also said the same thing and before
historical memory it is final theory
mentioned that and also is in
journal-constitution is an article that
a leader is the representative of the
citizen not representative of Serena
your purchase so it means that it's some
kind of representation and it's very
close to democracy so we have three
different approaches along our
generations Thank You professor would
you like to comment I'd like to thank
the speakers for coming here today for
any student responding study today
serious all-star lineup um so my
question is slightly timely with usher
on in about few weeks my question is
what would do events like the Battle of
Karbala or the occupation of the 12th
Imam serve in terms of a historical
philosophically or even as an allegory
as the foundation for some of the
post modern theories in terms of the way
in which jurisprudence politics and
theology you know mangle a lot of others
or both glossaries little Shiism have
argued that you know events like the
Battle of Karbala highlight the
separation between the political power
and JJ redick or even theological power
and proto Sunni the album or Sunni
orthodoxy so how do these clerical
figures are invertible figures or
interested in politics use these sorts
of events in the early time period is GE
Islam and what sort of developments to
bc in sunni islam today and do you have
a preferred responded to your question
the probably dr. a day or even dr. Cuddy
mar even on the coldest I don't all of
our life alternatives let me just say
that Professor cold is written eight
among many important ports a book on the
deputy and the Millennium which
addresses a very large extent the kind
of question that he raised the
significance of religious ideas in
Shiism in the late nineteenth and early
twentieth century and their impact so I
like the dress I would like to ask
professor Cole to take this question
first well the sacred history and she is
and centers around the larger than
saying grandson of the Prophet Muhammad
and of course the ritual calendar of I'm
she is amiss very much focused on that
as well and the way in which that of
that story of martyrdom and get justice
he is reflected in the part of the boat
shed world I was talking about insist on
easy rock is that it's constantly
referenced during the American
occupation and the she is ugly Rock are
inscribed on the body of the same so
they they have been martyred by Saddam
in some cases by the Americans and
British and so forth and as we say made
this principle stand against tyranny so
they represent themselves as as any s
journey so it's a bit it's a way of
invoking what often one is a religious
which will relatively detached and
politics for nationalist purposes and
and also to make claims on political
leadership in imposed on Iran thank you
for physical in the interest of time we
have three questions lined up I will
move to the next question and then later
if analyst
to address that question of yours we'll
come back to that his this is very good
news people heard dr. what's happenin so
you mentioned that SN ramezani was one
of the first or the first to teach the
book of in and out of me and I was
wondering if there were too many
scholars prior to him who taught
earphone in other ways whether it was
permitted none of you or not and then
also were there non-moving scholars who
talked about your pond in any way before
this so was this kind of the provide or
the start of Iran okay thank you well
I'm sure
doctor penny dr. we've done more about
this but he'll from the as subtly period
when Bulldogs I drove me into
interpreted given army into sky turns
and the people have looked to thought
you'd never be I'd circumstances and its
really the mall outside rods version
that he's dumb quotes I was
understanding kazoo so I can and but the
people go back at since the 17th century
taught this mystical philosophy and I
have to say all parts and solid work
with a lot ? Tigers of Egyptian
employment and yet had bagels with
woodsman and I don't think anybody was
anyway so any it morally had it
following everywhere and it always had
clerics who saying this lack of the Guru
the fact that it would you he's a which
is a pantheist because I game somebody
things contrary to some extent of the
Sun and understand your palate will not
thank you for facilitating first I'd
like to thank that hurt him it was very
engaging event and thank the organizers
as well my question is for dr. pol you
mentioned that I to assist on
specifically as called for unity between
two names and shields edelman I has also
done a similar once as well
recently at least in the past five six
years there's an increase of violence
within communities from Indonesia to
Malaysia to Pakistan list goes on human
in Houston targeting communities so
what has been the response from cipa
simulator 50 be spotless and as they're
going back and forth is there some free
reconciliation because the violence
seems to keep on increasing globally
yeah well there are there there is
violence between Sunnis and Shiites
sometimes in places karachi has seen a
wave of violence of that stored up in
Coweta as well in pakistan in Iran of
course although he robbed you know you
have to question how much of it is so HD
and how much it is just like Xbox ease
and you know cydia logical young man I
think the Syrian Revolution has pitched
the issue a new so I think maybe some of
the tensions we're starting to die down
but now you have this kind of demon dog
even though you know
party syria's is not religious party the
upper echelon so that are dominated by
on white or colored it as a kind of
Shiite they're not usually universe or
anything but it so happens that they are
coded as st ives and there are Salafi
Sunnis in Syria who have targeted how
the lights from reprisal and and then
the Iranian regime and you see item
government of Iraq has swung behind
Bashar al-assad a lot with the new party
government which is backed by Hezbollah
in Lebanon so it looks like there's a
kind of static backing for the elastin
regime at a time when Saudi Arabia Qatar
and most of the city world including
Muslim Brotherhood
is more aligned with revolutionaries but
this is a big problem Sistani zone
position has been that he saw did the
tactic that that the radical Sunnis in
Iraq developed which was to try to
foment a civil war by continually
modeling this GI so they would bond
their ice cream parlors and kill their
kids there would be a funeral at that
evening they would bomb the funeral
remodeled marriages it was a slaw with
the people that they were trying to get
the Shiites go because they were
convinced that they were a majority and
if they could throw the country into
civil war it would make it too hot for
the Americans to stay Americans from the
Frog and then they can make a cooling
come back to power and there was a
stupid theory first of all they're a
small minority in Iraq the men
Bertie and second of all if is they got
machetes go they would just be messenger
which is what actually happened see
study was very distressed by all this
and people would come to them about this
GI tribes and say our wedding was blown
up and we know which tribe did we know
where they live we want your permission
to go and take vetch because they have
power the formal kinds of heating
avenged among the tribes and she studied
for that them he said if the Sudanese
kill half the Shiites in Iraq I will not
print any crisis and I was a very
principled stand it actually I think had
some impact two thousand three four five
but then by 2006 nobody was any music to
it and by his own juridical lights right
you should have tried to get out ahead
of dirt your own following when they
stopped listening to him he with you he
stopped he stopped saying anything
and even for a while he stopped seeing
people at his home and so he was furious
at that horrible civil war that occurred
in 2006-2007 or 3,000 people of David
showing it was neighborhoods moving at
the inquest does really really
discouraged Sistani but in recent years
he has re-emerged to be this voice for
communal harmony and he has rested and
he has you know yes found Sunni leaders
who reciprocated will visit
they will come out but you know these
stories about being done by the hi Bob
they were behind thank you now the last
question this evening first of all I'd
like to thank each of the panelists for
really excellent than insightful
presentation that really took a lot of
them I'm not a student of Shia Islam War
Iran's very big learning expansion but I
wanted to do was a question for each of
the panelists based on the appointment
professor cool alluded to to the end
about how the one sense is that was
Brotherhood might be adapting borrowing
certain ideas of guardianship Majerus
today in certain respects and I see bed
with car dolly is worth Virginia
internet was wondering what extent his
evolution of the ocean the guardianship
of the jurist and she litical and social
thought what way is it actually
communicate with the Sunni world what's
going on the sooner world at the same
time the radiation of the Susa become
you know that that's clearly this is
echoes of some of you will have it you
know
by the time so just briefly each of you
comment on what you sense is the
relationship between the inclusion of
cheap thought and practice in relation
to the silly moments if there isn't
thank you very much does a lengthy
question it takes a lengthy answer in
four minutes after part time that we
have to give up this room but I think
the question is important enough to what
answers from Memphis profess metete it's
bigger than you I think that there is
some similarity in the side of insider
she thought as Professor GAO shu kare
che cavolo in drama here because we'll
remember when spoken his seminar around
the time the Iranian Revolution I said
that the a party school will make a
comeback
and that's when the best kickers are
very a heaven and smell about farting
around no doubt about it and the
epistemological point of the task et's
is that knowledge of the Quran the
sayings of the Imams he has just primacy
and histological Primus gates prime a
patient before you talk about knowledge
and arrived wreath they don't say that
homeless to reason they realize but you
know it doesn't send a verse of the
Quran characteristic on the reasoning
but they they put these kind of
knowledge by rotation and yes a lot of
the properties really have the same
approach I keep it on decision this is a
difficult there is a similarity I don't
know that any specific so do you think
my
is she really a true voice the first
part was communication of Sharia is
second five
divine right for the Jews I think the
Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt in studio in
India in all these countries share this
first part is the condition of Sharia
and some hinges LED flashing the bomb
also participated in the second Iran
exactly what she alternatively it's all
of the trees or the people of the
experience is that they had this job to
read a ruler so I mean it has a lot of
effect on the Swami's especially on the
first Thank You professor Cole you're
just very briefly the UH well any robbed
the Sudanese were at a disadvantage
because there they had no religious
hierarchy and was just individual
newer organized they lost the Baath
Party which was really what had
organized them so you see the emergence
in the couple of years after the fall of
Saddam of capsules of Sunni clergy and
then in the newspapers you start seeing
this phrase mar gaya or or you know
source of authority which is a Shiite
technical term now you know history is
long and texts are many and I can't tell
you with certainty that no student has
ever used the phrase where died here
before but I ever heard about anything
like that and I've written a lot of the
text so I think this is new and and then
not only has this phrase emerged among
the certainty clergy to claim a kind of
authority you know analogous to what
this guy claims you claim but it right
now there's a big debate in Egypt and
the framing of the new constitution that
was the Brotherhood wants to give the
Allies our seminary writes a review over
legislation to make sure it's and
importance with Islam 1906 giu audion
constitution and a lab notes that's
bring this evening that those
and please step outside for some
refreshments future